so the first thing you want to do is go
to your App Store and download Khan
Academy kids
once you've done that you can open our
app and you'll be greeted by our fun
characters
you'll be taken to a sign up screen
click sign up and enter your email
we use this email to create your account
and we're going to ask you to verify it
so once you've entered it and clicked
next you'll receive an email in your
email inbox
and you want to click the verify email
button in that email and then you're set
to go back into the app and start
creating accounts for your kids
click next here
and here you are
first we're going to add the name of our
first child Kim Kim is six and we'll
select an avatar for Kim
a dolphin ready to start learning now
but we'll quickly show you how to create
a profile for another child if you swipe
up into the parents section you'll see
Kim's account there tap the new button
swipe up and enter the name of the next
child Oscar
Oscar is actually older he's seven and
he is going to be a tiger
and now we have two children's profiles
Kim and Oscar we're going to start
learning with Kim so we tap Kim
and if we press the play button here
we'll be in our personalized learning
path it'll serve up age-appropriate
activities for your child like this one
if you wanted to do self-serve you could
click in the top left corner on the
library icon then you can scroll through
all of our activities books videos our
reading our logic social emotional
learning and you can pick out what your
child works on we've partnered with
National Geographic and Bellwether media
to offer a range of characters and
stories and formats to keep your child
busy and there's always the offline
functionality that suitcase under the
word Library we can't wait for you to
discover everything there is to do on
Khan Academy kids